[музика]
компетентнісне навчання і ці методики
можна застосовувати маючи
сучасні засоби навчання тому що
інформаційні технології данують нам
абсолютно нові можливості це освітній
портал в якому ми викладемо всі
навчальні нові матеріали якими зможуть
користуватися незалежно від місця
проживання всі україн Діти там повинні
бути також відеоуроки там повинні бути
дистанційні курси зокрема які є дуже
важливими для наших дітей що залишились
не своєї волі на окупованих
непідконтрольних територіях і які
прагнуть продовжувати освіту в Україні
ми зобов'язані створити цей портал це є
у наших планах і це є частиною плану
реалізації нової української
школи
сучасна тимедійна бібліотека в кожній
школі ми розуміємо що сьогодні освітній
простір не обмежується будівлею школи і
роль учителя і самої школи дуже
змінилася раніше дитина приходила в
школу за знаннями а сьогодні Вчитель -
це модератор у Великому морі інформації
і тому як він має навчити як
використовувати шукати цю інформацію
класифікувати і тично
переосмислювати